wir haben mit zwei verschiedenen fällen
zu tun bei dem ein anderer verbrechen
geht der vorwurf des sexismus im raum
und bei der bahn geht es sozusagen um
homophoben ansatz und ich muss sagen
dass ich finde dass er sich mit dieser
aussage auch disqualifiziert hat als
kandidat für mich ist das sozusagen ein
gestriges verhalten und ein ansatz wenn
man über das thema homosexualität
spricht und im selben atemzug sozusagen
pädophile damit assoziiert dann ist das
nicht das problem des jähnigen den er
meint sondern derjenige der das
sozusagen ausspricht und ich glaube
deutlich wird es daran das ist natürlich
so ist das wenn auch heterosexuelle
einvernehmlich sozusagen miteinander in
austausch gehen dass das auch den
gesetzen entsprechen muss man aber nie
auf die idee kommen würde in dem fall zu
sagen aber aber beim thema pädophile und
und kinder und so weiter müssen wir
eingrenzen und ich finde das hat das
beispiel ganz deutlich gezeigt dass
konservativ nicht gleich konservativ ist
denn denjenigen der dort anspricht das
ist ja jens spahn der für einen modernen
konservativismus steht und ich finde das
ist das bild des ewiggestrigen und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe lieber
einen homosexuellen kanzler als eine
homophobe
[Musik]